Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Loki,
a tool for collecting logs
on bare metal Kubernetes and a whole bunch
of other things from the team at Grafana.
Now before we get started and dive into
Loki in a little bit more detail and
get hands on, we just got a little
bit of housekeeping.
First and foremost, please, if you're not already
subscribed to the YouTube channel, do that now.
Use the bell to get notifications for all
future episodes.
If you're not watching live, but you wanna
have a little bit of a conversation about
what you see in today's episode or any
other episode, then you can join the Discord
server.
We've got a couple of hundred cloud native
enthusiasts and Kubernetes people all talking about cloud
native technologies and general technologies. Come and join
us, get involved.
And lastly, I wanna thank Equinix Metal. They
are my employer, but they allow me to
spend time during my working day producing this
channel and these episodes so that we can
all learn the vast cloud native landscape together.
So thank you Equinix Metal. You can use
the code Rawkode for $200 off compute.
You can spend that on just fifty hours
or four hundred hours. That is entirely up
to you. Have some fun.
Right. Now
today, I am joined by from
the Grafana team, maintainer of the Loki project.
Hi there. How are you?
Hello. Hello, David. Hi. I'm good. Thank you.
And you? Yeah. I'm doing really well. Thank
you. Actually, I mean, I'm excited to dive
into Loki and and see how it can
improve my logging pipelines.
So very excited to take this session. Nice.
Do you want to give us a brief
introduction about yourself? And then we'll kind of
talk about Loki and what it is.
Yeah. Sure. So I've been working at Grafana
for two years now, and I'm a software
engineer there. And I've mostly been involved with
Loki,
a bit of Cortex, but mostly Loki. So
I'm Loki expert, so don't hesitate to ask
any question regarding
Loki.
Nice. Awesome.
So why don't we kinda just
talk about, like,
what is Loki?
Like, what what what give me the, like,
the the three word patch if there is
one. What does Loki do?
Oh, three three word. That's I'm gonna need
a little bit more. But Alright. Alright. I'll
give It's
actually, it's
five words. Five words. Good. It's like properties
it's like properties, but for the dogs.
That's that's the idea. But, no, more seriously,
it's a log aggregation system
where you can send all your application logs
to, and it will aggregate all of them
in a central place where you can, you
know, query them back. And it's heavily inspired
by Promotus.
One of the big difference that
it takes compared to other
system out there is that it doesn't really
index
the
content itself, just the metadata. A bit like
Prometheus, you know, the the the labels, how
they work.
In Loki, the idea is a bit the
same. You index only the labels itself of
the of the of the workload, so not
the content. And that makes it, you know,
very, inexpensive
to run,
because the index is very small at the
end of the day.
In some system, you can end up with
an index that is actually bigger than the
than the content itself.
And so in that in that case, that
makes the operational workload very,
very difficult.
And I think, Loki, that's that's what it's
nice with Loki. It's bit easier to run.
Is it is it easier to run and
is it is it to scale too? Is
it is it fair to say that Loki
then is a database?
Is that the correct way to look at
it? So
yeah. I mean, we since it has its
own Loki language, I guess we could say
that it's a database.
The
thing to note, though, is we rely on
on
giants.
We we mostly
allow people to save data
in in object storage, like
Google Cloud Storage or s Amazon s three.
So we're not, like,
really
storing the data
ourselves, but we do replication to make sure
that, you know, when you ingest the data,
we don't lose if the data if there's
any any node that is going down.
We
so that's, yeah, that's the that's the idea.
You can also
store the data on disk if you're in
running the single binary, and I believe that's
what we're gonna do today.
In that case,
you know, it's it's it's more for a
single cluster.
So if you need to scale above that,
like you have a lot of cluster, you're
probably gonna want to look at using an
object store. It's gonna be easier anyway to
to operate. Right? It's it's it's easier than
PVCs.
I'm pretty sure, like, everyone out there knows,
you know, how difficult it can be
to operate a stateful set and PVCs.
Yeah. I'm I'm sure anyone watching who's run
stateful workloads in Kubernetes knows exactly how easy
all of that stuff is these days. Right?
Yeah.
Hopefully, the sarcasm can clear loud and clear
there. Stateful workloads are are as much as
I encourage it in Kubernetes, still a pain
in the ass. But let's
get my screen shared. We have here the
Grafana Loki webpage and documentation.
Yeah. There's the, like, Prometheus but for logs
line that you gave me with the file.
Exactly.
So I I mean, I kind of compared
it to database, but even in the the
first line here and I know it's a
little bit small, so let's just zoom in.
But it says Loki is actually a set
of components
that can be composed in the fully featured
logging stack. So do you wanna break that
down us? What are the what are the
components of Loki?
Yeah. So the
so there's no super way to run Loki.
Today, we're just gonna do a single binary,
a bit like Promotus, which only scale
vertically.
And that's already good enough for a single
cluster.
But in fact, we created Loki for our
own usage on Grafana so that we can
receive terabytes of data from customer
around the world. So Loki can also scale
using
a distributed
version,
which is splitted into multiple components.
So there's you know, there there there's a
lot of different component in in the system.
But the idea is there's a distributors that
will receive the data
and validate the data, then it will pass
it down to ingestors.
Ingestors are are basically compressing the data
and
saving that in the object store.
And then after, you
know, you have the quarries that will query
back the data.
Yeah. So this schema here that we're looking
at is
a bit summarizing
what I'm saying. There's two ways to unlock
it. Today, we're just going go with the
simple one. There's a more complex one.
If you're really into it, you have time,
you you know,
wanna you wanna run Rookie with
at very large scale,
then then you can use that. Is that
these these are the components you mentioned. Right?
Distributor and JS, query front end and and
query. And this is all documented
in there.
Well, quite easy to find it through the
documentation.
Exactly. Yeah. If you wanna know more, I
guess we we're not gonna go through too
much into this because, you know, like every
distributed system,
it's kind of complex. We could talk for
hours about this.
Yeah.
But that's that's the idea. It's nice to
talk about it and to have a nice
overview of the different components, the potential architectures.
But, you know, we we really just wanna
get a hands on with this, don't we?
We wanna kick the tires. We wanna play
with it. We wanna see how cool it
is. And people can, in your own time,
feel free to jump into the docs and
do a bit of a deeper dive there.
Yep. Yeah. There's there's lots going on here.
So There is a lot of documentation about
it. We try to be very transparent about
what we're we're building here. Yeah. Good documentation
is something that I love to see on
this show. I wish it was, like, the
the standard
for all open source projects, but that's not
the case. And I'll include my own in
that. My documentation for all of my projects
is the worst documentation in the world. So
I really appreciate it when I find other
projects.
It's a it's a team effort, and we
recently got a new hire in the team
who's gonna who's actually a technical writer. So
he's gonna spend a lot of time improving
this documentation. So all of this has been
written so far by developers.
You know
Nice. It is how it is.
Okay. So we are gonna I have prepared
let's do the what have I done upfront
component of the show? I have a Kubernetes
cluster running on Equinix metal.
It has nothing on the default namespace, but
we do have the weave works.
Oh, where's my Why is it not all
complete? Oh, there we go. We do have
the weave works sock shop microservice demo deployed
to the cluster.
I just did that to create some arbitrary
noise, hopefully get some logs into Yeah. Into
Loki. We made it say to deploy something
else, that's perfectly alright, but I just thought
I'd give us maybe a little bit of
a head start with some of the boring
stuff there. And of course, we do have
the control plane if we wanna get the
logs out of that too.
And something you mentioned as we were chatting
just before we went live is that you
can get quite meta with this. Loki can
read its own logs.
Yeah. I'll have a a little bit of
fun with that as well.
There's various installation methods. We can go with
with Tanka.
I think I'm gonna avoid that today. I
think the whole Tanka thing is something we
could do an entirely own episode on. Yeah.
What Tanka is and how to do it.
Do you wanna share anything about Tanka before
we jump into helm though?
Do you want to give us, like, more
Yeah. That's
mhmm. Yeah. TANCA is is
it's
really the same purpose as Helm as, you
know, deploying,
you know, describing your infrastructure
and and your workload with code,
except that we use Gsonnet and not
I think it's what's the the template the
Go template, I think. Go template. Yeah. But
yeah. And so with Tinker, we use Gsonnet,
which is a language that is a bit
more flexible.
But it's also
less well known and a bit more difficult
to learn. But it has this nice flexibility.
And that's what we use at Gafana Labs
to deploy
all the workload that we have. So that's
why the we we recommend Tenka because, you
know, there's more chance that you're gonna have,
you know, the latest version because we we
try to
always make Tenka up to date. But Elm
is more like a community, so we don't
we don't, you know, we don't we don't
ourselves look
at Elm that much, and we don't run
it with Elm on our side. So it's
easier for us to help you if you're
using Thinker. But Elm, you know, I've I've
been using it too for
deploying
Loki for testing, and it's it's it's working,
you know, like a charm too.
Nice.
Yeah. I mean, I'll I'll kind of add
one thing here. I I I think Helm
is great,
but I really dislike Go templates. And I
find it really difficult to maintain my Helm
charts with the amount of options that users
want
while trying to make it still legible, readable,
understandable, all these things. It can be really
difficult and I I love seeing your tooling
in this space come up to try and
hopefully
solve
some of those challenges. Yeah, I'd love to
do a Tanker episode one day for sure.
Yeah. One of the one of the big
win that I like with Tanker, this is
something that happened to me a lot in
in my previous experience,
is how many times have you deployed
an application in the wrong cluster, like in
production? Or you applied applied the change
because the context your context was not the
right one.
Tenkara doesn't really rely on on your current
context. It relies on the
context that is set in the folder. So
of you know?
There's a gist there's a JSON file that
describes the the cluster that you should be
targeting for that folder. And it will always,
you know, target that one. So there's less
chance to make a mistake, like deploying an
update in pod or removing a pod in
pod or anything like that.
Yeah. I I do that all the time.
I am juggling so many clusters
for these episodes, for my day job, for
my open source projects,
and I should get better at using Dart
End and having KubeConfigs thrown around or even
just better tooling my context. But I I
do it all the time. I'm always deploying
stuff to Docker for Mac because I mean
to put somewhere else or to the wrong
yeah. I feel that. Yeah. Okay.
Let's jump to the You to do Docker
format and Docker format and instead you deployed
prod. That's too awesome. Take care of it.
See, because I also have a show called
Clustered where I have to spend up to
multiple clusters every week, and one of the
things I keep doing is deploying Cluster API
to my production cluster instead of Docker for
Mac, and it's it's it's a pain in
the ass. Anyway, I'm gonna rant about that
another day, not today. What we'll do today
is
add our helm repository.
Yeah.
Don't have to check my context because I
already ran get nodes and get pods. I'm
good. Okay.
You you gave me the fear now.
Run our repository update, which I don't think
I probably needed with the repo ad, but
it's all good. And what I see here
is we have a couple of options for
deploying locator or cluster. Mhmm.
We've got something called a Loki stack. We've
got a Loki stack over PVC. We've got
a slightly different Loki stack.
Yep. You wanna run us through these options
if you don't mind?
Yeah. They're they're just so Loki stack is
really an umbrella chart,
And a lot of people are using it
just to get started and and play with
the the whole stack of Loki, Ponte plus
Grafana
and and added bonus parameters too.
So
all of those different type of installation just,
you know, activate, deactivate
one of the component or or or persistent
volume or depending on what you're looking for.
You can even just use if you want
to instead of.
So this is just Viya's. It's it's the
same stack, but with Viya's,
you know, configuration enable and disable. I would
suggest that we go with the, yeah, the
one you have your mouse on, the one
that's deployed in Skafana and Prometheus.
Yeah. Let's go with this one. So for
I know what FluteBit is. I I know
I've I've used that a fair bit in
my career. I have never used Promptail. Can
you give me the what what is is
that just a
Yep. No. That's a very good very good
question, David. The the the idea of of
is,
you know, there's already a lot of client
for fetching logs, but there's none of them
that really
mimic the service discovery from Prometheus.
Right. And that's all the reason why we
have Prometheus. We wanted to have the same
experience as you will install Prometheus,
configure your
labels to be extracted and fetched with the
Kubernetes service discovery.
And Prometheus is exactly the same configuration.
So you have more chance to have the
same label set
for the workload for your logs and your
metrics if you're using Pontail than using Finbit.
It's a bit more difficult. I'm not saying
it's impossible, but it's going to be more
difficult. If you're coming from Prometheus world, Prometheus
will be much more easier to configure. Alright.
Awesome. Thank you for that. Okay. So we're
gonna deploy Loki Loki stack with Prometheus.
Now I'm curious. One last thing and we'll
get on to something a bit more interesting,
but
we have an option for web and without
a PVC.
I'm going to deploy the one without even
though we do have the ability to have
persistent volumes on our cluster, but I'm just
curious if I do it without the PVC,
does that mean if Loki restarts,
we lose our data, or is it using
host path or something else?
Yeah. No.
I I don't think it by default, it
uses all sparse, so you will lose the
data if you restart. Yeah. And we're okay
with that for today. Right? So Yeah. We're
okay with that. Yeah. Definitely.
I never told you. We're deploying this into
prod today for my real work cluster. So
I should probably use PVC.
Exactly.
You want to use PVC if you're, yeah,
if you're deploying on a production cluster or
anything like that.
Alright. So does this create
no namespace? I'm assuming we've got some stuff
in our default. There we go. Nice. Yeah.
Everything is starting. Yeah. So I see Loki
zero. That means we've got a stateful set
running here with with one pod. I'm gonna
assume
we've got Grafana. Yeah. KubeStateMetrics.
Nice. We don't have to deploy that. That
is always a win.
We've got the Prometheus stack that we're all
know and comfortable with. And then we have
Yep. Promptail,
four of them. I'm assuming that is a
daemon set based on the It is. Yep.
Correct.
Yeah. I know some stuff. I'm not, you
know,
not really rubbish.
No. So the idea is Pontail is going
to run on each of the nodes.
And it's going to need so by the
way, I hope that this is going to
be fine. But it's going to need to
access the host path of the nodes so
that it can get the Docker logs
from the daemon itself.
And then it's gonna tail those files. And
with the service discovery, you're gonna be able
to attach Kubernetes metadata
to the logs and send them to Loki.
Awesome. Well, let's give that just a a
moment to kinda get healthy, get happy. We
do have a question from our audience. I'm
gonna pop that on the screen.
But Raja Sulent has asked
there's not read the manual pages yet, but
I do love the use of RTFN by
the way. Props to that. I cannot use
this to create a dynamic oh, no. See,
I was too busy enjoying the RTFM.
But can I use this to create a
dynamic dashboard with logs that I put into
the system so I can get a dashboard
to view the logs? So
does that make sense to you?
Can I
Hold on? I'll pull it back up one
more time. I think what they're asking is
is can I use this to create a
dashboard that just shows me the logs that
I'm putting into the system? I think that
is
You yeah. You can create a dash yeah.
You can create a dashboard. So, yeah, Grafana
now supports a log panel.
So not only you can use explore to
directly
explore the logs of your workload, but you
can also build the metric dash dashboard that
you you were before and then add the
logs within well, we're we're gonna be able
to do that today, I think. That's gonna
be fun. That sounds like a great idea.
I guess
alright. Let me throw it. Okay. We've deployed
this. And I know I should go back
to the docs, but I've got you right
in front of me, so I'm just gonna
throw at you anyway. Yeah. Because
we have the Promptail running as a daemon
set, because we have deployed this altogether,
I'm assuming
if I just browse to Grafana, I would
expect Promptail to already be shipping all of
my containers logs to Loki, and that we
can probably start to query that right away.
Is is that where we Yeah.
I expect the same thing, but, you know,
how it is live. So let's see. Yeah.
I expect that normally
when you when you get the the stack
working,
you should be able to to directly start
looking at the logs. Okay. I'm I'm gonna
assume, like, you know, Prometheus does ship really
basic UI out of the box. Does Loki
do anything like that, or does it really
rely on Grafana? Okay. It does it does
it does expose some sort of UI, but
nothing really
nothing really useful for us here. It's more
from an operator perspective.
So it's better that we look at Grafana.
Grafana is more the UI for this.
All right.
Is it going to be admin, admin? Or
am I going to have to find the
secret in the cluster? I
think it is admin. Oh, it's not. Yeah.
Alright. Let's export
my kube config.
Let's get
secret.
I I think I think there is one
already. I'm wondering what it is. It's not
so you tried admin admin.
I did. Yeah. There is a there is
a Loki Grafana secret here. I'm gonna assume
it's there. What I'll do is I'll just
pop up a follow-up question
which you can tackle while I do the
boarding bit for use case.
I get a bunch of syslogs from different
hosts, put them into Loki, use Grafana to
view and expect.
I think that's it. Yes. I think that's
what we're we're hopefully just about to do.
Sorry. I answered your question. Yeah. No.
No. No. You're you're right. I think the
question is really towards Syslog, which is less
Kubernetes.
But, yeah, you can do that. The the
the Pontail supports Syslog
receiver.
So you can stop Pontail.
It will run as a as a Syslog
server. You can send the log to Promptel
directly from all your different devices that you
have and it will ship them to to
Loki.
Alright.
I'm not gonna decode the username. I'm just
gonna hope that's the basic before hash for
admin.
Yeah.
Maybe not. Oh, no. That's just copied them
when I highlighted it.
Silly me.
There we go. Nice. Yeah. Cool.
Although otherwise, we could have just it and
changed the password.
No. No. No. No. We do. That's the
that's the installable
way. So it looks like we don't have
any starred dashboards at least, but has it
created
And it No. But we we do have
a no. There's no dashboard when you start.
But there is a there's a data source,
I think. If you look at it's in
yeah. This one, data sources. Yeah. Yeah. We
can see already Loki and Prometheus are connected.
Yeah. We'll try. Yeah. Okay. So we do
have them connected. That's great. I guess in
theory,
we can jump straight into explore and begin
to see what we have available to us.
Yeah. So you need to select a data
source at the top, I believe. Yeah.
Hi.
Yeah.
So
my first question then is
how do we interact with Loki?
I'm assuming it's not used in PromQL. I'm
assuming there's a Loki query language. Do you
want to walk us through this?
Yeah. So we call it LogQL,
Log Query Language.
And so there's a documentation on Grafana that
is very extensive on on everything
that you can do with LogQL. But the
idea is is really
inspired by Prometheus again. So the label selector
to select a metric, but for us, there's
no metrics. So it's just this label set
selector and the label matches
will be the same. So you can, you
know, choose one of them, and it will
write the query for you. So let's let's
go to app and select one.
Will we start with the meta query of
app Loki?
Yeah. Let's let's start with that. Yeah.
Oh, it it kinda does look like
PromQL,
at least the label selector syntax. Right? Yeah.
We're on a old version of Grafana. So
it needs to
it needs to you need to manually set
metric or logs at the top, as you
can see. There's a bit a switch button.
Yeah. If you click on logs. Yeah.
You can rerun the query now.
Alright.
Yeah. Should we should we try to update
it before going further, maybe? Do you think
that's You wanna upgrade Grafana? Yeah. Sure. Let's
do it. Yeah.
So it's just a default format called Loki
Grafana. And then she just wanna pop the
image to the latest. Right?
Yeah. That's it. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's do that. Good. Alright. So do
you know the version or should I go
to Docker Hub? I was about to look
at Docker Hub. What's the latest one?
R Grafana.
7.5,
I think. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's go with it. Even if it's
an experimental one,
it's gonna be better. It's gonna be better.
This is like a YOGO version that we're
looking at right now. Alright. Let's see what
was updated recently. Let's let's see. Should we
go nightly?
Nightly.
Whiskey.
755. Is a good one. Yeah. Yeah. Let's
go with this. I believe Grafana eight currently
in progress. Right?
Is is that Sorry? Is Grafana eight being
worked on at the moment?
Yep. Yeah. Because I'm pretty sure I've seen
something on Twitter recently about some big changes
to like the the I think all the
graphing panels are being redone and and stuff
like that. Yeah. Yeah. The the graph file.
Yeah.
Every every major version is once a year.
Nice.
So let's just see if
just initializing.
Let's assume the port forward is gonna.
Yeah. Think the password is gonna be on
the same too.
You think? Oh, come on. Yeah.
You know, don't forget I work on Loki.
I'm
I'm good with Grafana, but I'm not an
expert on Grafana. Great. Okay. I'll cut you
some slack then.
Okay. That port forward.
Maybe it's just not ready yet.
Yeah. It wasn't there.
Okay. Pods.
Yeah. Looks better now. Yep.
Should've saved it.
Should've saved the password.
Alright. Base sixty four d.
There we go.
Alright. Password's the same. We're back in.
Nice. We're on the Loki stores, and we
no longer have the logs and metrics.
Does that mean it's just working out?
Yep. That that this is all great. This
is gonna be way much easier for us
to write queries and and play with this.
Alright. Awesome.
So, what do we have here? Like, this
is
I mean, I'm trying guess what we've got
and I think we kind of briefly covered
it, but we're using LogQL.
We're looking for all of our container logs
from Kubernetes
where there was a label that existed called
app, where the value is locating the logs
of ourselves.
What we have here appears to be some
sort of times very sharp to show the
occurrence of logs over time and then we
is this just raw logs that we have
below? That's yeah. That's the whole logs.
You I think you have a a version
of Kubernetes
that
is using Creo logs.
So you can see, like, the SDRF.
This is the Creo format.
And we can we can configure Promptel to
get rid of that if we want
because that's gonna be
a bit difficult to pass after if we
need to pass it.
But, yeah, that's that's the whole log, actually,
from from the Docker daemon of each node.
Okay. Yeah. We can see the we can
see the the labels here. They're they're looking
good so far. So this is the this
top right here is just the labels from
the Kubernetes resource. And then the detected fields,
is this analyzing
the log line itself and trying to work
out what exists? Mhmm.
Yeah. That's directly from Grafana itself. It's not
from Loki. So Grafana, when it's showing those
line, it tried to detect some sort of
fields
and and does some
analysis on it.
Alright.
Nice.
Same goes for the the color. You see
that the the color, it's all green so
far. It's because it hasn't
found any errors. So Grafana will try automatically
to spot the errors in red for you.
Okay. Nice.
Alright. Looks like we have a couple of
questions that I'll drop up just now. So
Mozz is asking, does Loki support other log
shipping tools like Fluent Bit, Fluent D, File
Beats, or is it exclusive to Promptail?
We have kind of answered that, but I'll
let you I'll let you go for it
again.
Yeah. We we support all of them, the
except Filebit, because Filebit doesn't really have a
way to plug in an in an an
output
clients.
But we do have a lockstash, so you
can do file bit to lockstash to Loki
if you want.
But, yeah, we support FlinBits in the
I think we also support vector, which is
in REST.
We like, we have a docker driver also.
So there's, like there's no reason to to
not send the data to Loki. Like, we
have we
have all of them. There's a a follow-up
comment as well from Frank who's actually just
suggesting, hey. Loki has a REST API. So,
really, you could use anything to send the
logs. Yeah. Which is cool.
Alright. One more question and then we'll we'll
get back to our demo. Ad so I
was saying
they're looking to adopt Loki, they want to
adopt Loki, but they're curious to put handling
high throughput or high scale. An example I've
got there is roughly seven terabytes per day.
Yeah. Is within the realm of Loki? Is
is that good numbers, bad numbers? What's your
thoughts?
Yeah. It is. It is in the realm
of Loki.
It's difficult for me to think about this
per day because I'm usually thinking about this
per minute.
But it it would there there won't be
an issue
for
ingesting that amount of data. It's gonna be
actually very
very easy. Now if you want to query
over this huge amount of data, you may
have to go into the distributed setup.
But I will start always with starting with
a small Loki instance, see how it goes.
And if you need to scale up, then
at that time, start to look at the
more difficult scenario.
Yeah. I think that's great advice for all
software. Start with easy mode and when the
the car starts to shake at high speed,
maybe do some upgrades. Okay.
So this was cool. We created some logs.
What do you wanna what what should we
try and do next with this then?
So
there's multiple
option that we could do. I think we
need to fix this
logline format here.
Because you know that this F and STDR
is really about the,
and it doesn't really help us.
So we can try to fix this. It's
we need to look at the configuration
of
to do that.
And then after, I guess, we can maybe
show how the dashboarding works with Loki.
Yeah. That would be cool. Yeah.
So
we need to look at the m chart,
how we can change the configuration. It's very
easy. We just need to actually add a
single line.
But I I'm not sure we can do
it
without creating a value file. So let me
Oh, we can just modify the config map
in lane, though. Right?
I don't need to redeploy this with Helm
anymore, so I'm quite happy just to modify
the config map in the cluster. Yeah.
Yeah. That sounds good. So let's go down.
I'm looking for pipeline stages,
which basically
yep. That's it. So we're we're set up
for Docker. That's not what we have here.
We have container. So, basically,
yeah, we have yeah. Exactly. So we need
to change. And it's CRI.
You just need to change that to CRI.
Yeah.
And that should do it.
And maybe that's the case also if you
try this at home. I know that Kubernetes,
the latest version, is going to our CI.
Before, it was Docker format.
And the Docker format is kind of like
a JSON log.
So you can quickly identify which one you
have. If you have the one we have
today, like a STDR,
it means it's a CI. If you have
a JSON and you are not logging in
JSON,
it's most likely because you are using the
Docker format.
Alright. Well, I've triggered a rollout of that
daemon set. Let's just give that,
Hopefully, not too long. I guess maybe about
a minute for it to to run through
them all.
Yeah. It should be no. It should be
quick.
Nice nice Cube Cattola skills that you have.
Yeah.
I like to learn things the hard way,
so
live debugging is getting easier for me these
days.
Okay. Yeah. I can see that. We have
another question. So let's answer this question. Hopefully,
the the rollout has has done its job
and
we'll do some dashboarding and take it hopefully,
we can take into log QL bit more
and and see. Yeah. And of course, like,
well, I'm sure we'll we'll get to this
naturally, but how do we turn on index
and for specific fields and and the process
of doing that? Anyway, question. Yep.
So is
asking, okay, there's fluidity, fluid bit, telegraph, Loki.
Can you briefly position those components which are
overlapping more or less? Second question.
Well, let's start with the first. So fluent
d, fluent bit, telegraph, Loki,
I think you're gonna think they're all in
the same space. You wanna elaborate on that
at all?
Yeah. I think they are overlapping,
and it's it's a bit like free and
d. I guess, you know, it's in Ruby.
So the the the the people that created
free and d realized, oh, maybe we need
to move away from Ruby and and write
a a c plus plus client. So that's
how, I guess, free and bit came to
life.
Telegraph, I don't think Telegraph has a has
a low key output.
And I don't think that's the case. I
think it can only only send to Influx
from what I know. Telegraph can write to
Influx Elasticsearch,
HTTP
endpoints,
and gRPC. It's a personal bunch of things.
I don't think there is a native Loki
output Yeah. Yet.
But you could probably do it with the
HTTP output, I would have thought. I'll I'll
hack on that one day.
Yeah.
So, yeah, definitely. I mean, Loki is really
the database.
Three and d, three and bit telegraph are
more agent, right, for collecting data. That's that's
the biggest difference.
So Loki doesn't really overlap all of those.
You just need someone to send the logs
to to to
to itself.
Alright. And then the second part of that
question was with regards to the recent license
change on the Grafana products. Is Loki a
part of that? I guess, is Loki now
a GPL?
Yeah. That's a good question. Yeah. So I
don't remember. I think it was last week
this change happened,
which was before we we talked together, David.
And, yeah, not everything is AGPL
in in in Loki.
Mostly everything that is clients, so Pontel,
everything
that the user,
you know,
will use to send data, but also to
process the logline itself is not AGPL. It's
still Apache two. So you can all you
know, you can you can you
can use that in your open source project
if you need to without having
to
license AGPL,
your own project.
Now for most people, they they usually don't
integrate Loki itself, but more the client, so
it shouldn't really affect anyone.
Alright. Nice. Thanks for clearing that up. Okay.
We have now rotated our Promptail.
We have switched the pipeline stage from Docker
to container runtime interface.
Yeah. It's running, so that's a good sign.
Well, yeah, we didn't break it. That's great.
So let's do the last five minutes. This
is already refreshing,
and we have much cleaner log lanes sitting
here now. Right? Yes. This is what you're
working.
Yeah. That's what I was expecting. This is
exactly,
like, what what you would expect from your
application,
nothing else from the infrastructure behind. So that's
much better. Alright. We got confirmation from Stanislav
there that Telegraph does now have a Loki
output. So that's great. Awesome.
Yeah. I didn't know about this. Nice. I
worked for Influx for two years, and I
didn't know about it. So I
wouldn't judge you for missing it.
Alright. Yeah. I mean, we can play with
the log browser. The log browser is a
new feature. I really like it. So you
can click on that and see and see
how that goes.
Okay. So what do you want me to
click on? Sorry.
Next to the next to the query,
there's a there's a button named log
browser
with a little shovel. Yeah.
We have a shovel?
Yeah. No. Yeah.
It's
on the left. Oh, right. Got you. Got
you. Yeah. Yeah, this one. Yeah. So this
if you're a bit scared of LokiL at
first, this is a nice way to get
started. So at the top,
see all the other label
names.
And also, that's a good way to see
if you're wasting or using things that you
shouldn't be using.
But you can click on, for instance, on
job one. The job the job is an
interesting one.
And once you do that, you see all
the
all the the values
that exist for this one.
And that's kind of a nice way to
browse your data without being an expert in
or
knowing how to use that language.
So yeah, you can select one that you
want, maybe Grafana, Loki Grafana if you want
the default one. So job is basically a
namespace plus
contained name. That's what it is. Okay.
And then Yeah. So you can, yeah, show
logs.
And there's no log for that one.
Or maybe not no log for yeah.
Last hour. Yeah.
There we are.
So if you if you're running I don't
know if we're running currently
a deployment that are that has more than
multiple
the more than one
pod. Do you do we have that? I
don't I'm not sure.
Let's have a look. Let's see what we've
got in the stock shop. We can always
scale one of these up. Oh, everything is
one. Yeah. Let's just modify one. So let's
get this a little bit more interesting.
We're gonna do edit
deployment.
Should modify
orders.
We check the log first to make sure
they output log?
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, let's make sure there is
log. But yeah.
Yeah. Whatever logs there is. Yeah. That's good.
Yeah. Let's go with this. Just wanna show,
you know, that with Loki, you can you
can find
logs for a single pod if you need
to using labels.
Order
replicas.
Yeah. Sketch. There we go. Oh, yes. Six.
It's a big cluster. We might as well
have a problem with it.
Sure. Sure. Alright. So this was our orders
sock shop. So I'm gonna try and use
the log browser. And what is the Yep.
Turn
off job.
Oh, I really should have checked the labels,
shouldn't I?
Maybe order. Maybe it's name order. No. Deploy
order.
Let's see. What labels do we have?
Name orders. Alright.
The name
orders.
And we have a few options here, so
why don't we talk about that? So we
already clicked on show logs. It showed us
all the logs from those pods.
What are the other two options here?
So show log rate will, I believe,
create a metric query out of the selector
to show
the log rate of that stream. So we
we call it stream
set of
log from one or more different
pod.
And this will just show the rate of
it. And validate is just basically trying to
see if the query that you craft is
actually valid because you can change it manually.
Yeah,
it's valid. Yeah, that's good. Okay, let's see
the logs. And,
yep, these are the logs from
that process.
Yep. So think I've checked the Java one,
unfortunately. Sorry about that.
No. That's okay. No. That's okay. We're not
gonna pass it too much.
What
we could do is look a bit about
the labels, if
you can see if they are from different
pods. So if you expand
a couple of lines,
you should be able to see that
the pod is different from time to time.
Yeah. This is this one.
So would we be able to,
like because this like, with LogQL, could I
actually group by the pod and see how
many different pods there are?
Yeah. We can do that. Let's do that.
So I'm gonna help you to write this
down. We're gonna write at the beginning.
Alright.
Actually, we're gonna do a wait.
Do rates
and then open parenthesis.
Yeah. So that's exactly like Punkyard. You you
should feel
so, yeah, you have the selector the range
selector here. So it's brackets.
Square square bracket.
And, yeah, select interval.
Interval will automatically
the first one. Yeah. Automatically select the interval
that we are using on the range currently.
Okay. And you can run that. If there's
not too many label, it should it should
go fine.
Let's run that to see.
I can't hit return.
Yeah. You can hit the the blue button
at the top. I don't remember what's the
key. Yeah. Yeah. It's probably commanded or something,
isn't it? Yeah. Yeah.
So we need to
I think the interval was maybe just too
big here.
The yeah. The top the the the time
shift. If you look at the top next
to clear all
yeah. Yeah. Click on this button next to
the the loop.
Oh, yep. No.
It's more on the left, not the clear
hole. Not this one. Yeah. Left again. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. That one. Yeah. Yeah. Let's change
it to maybe five minutes or fifteen minutes.
Yeah.
And, yeah, we we can so it shows
too many label right now. So if you
know Prometheus, you can do a sum by
to aggregate
by pod. I think it's pod.
Yeah. We can do a sum by pod.
You can wrap everything by with a sum
by pod. Sum and then yeah. No. So
there's no there's a space between
yeah. There's a space between sum and buy.
Yeah. And then open parenthesis
right after the yeah. Pod,
close the parenthesis, and then you wrap everything
into parenthesis at
the end. Yeah. Is that right? So you
need to wrap it again. Yeah. You need
to wrap again the rate into parenthesis one
more time.
That's how
yeah. Yeah.
So that's going to send by pod this
time.
So it's going to remove all the label
dimension and only keep the pod. Ah, there
we go. Nice. Yeah. So this
pod doesn't seem to log
a lot just at the beginning when it's
tough.
Yeah. I think it's
the pod's all started up. It's about a
little bit of log. I mean, we're not
browsing to the sock shop. We're not adding
things to cars and trying to cause more
load data. We we could definitely do that
if we want, but I think we we've
seen what we wanted to see here. And
we've seen a burst of calls. Right. Yeah.
We you know, it's nice. I mean, I
I don't think I understand LogQL
in GridDef or anything, but I like the
familiarity with PromQL.
It's not too dissimilar.
So I think I could probably work my
way through a few examples there. So that's
pretty cool. Yeah. I think that's the idea
of why LokiL is heavily inspired by PromQL
is to make it simple for people that
are already
comfortable with PromQL
to learn
this new language.
And if there's something that I can add
is if you scroll up to the query,
is in
Loki,
the only difference
between Loki and PromptQL is the log queries.
So this is a metric query because it
output a metric query. So all the metric
queries are very exactly
the same as in PromptQL.
The log queries where you can search world
RegEx world or grep world,
those use Pipe.
And those are
more
new to
the space.
Okay. So could we
search for default lifecycle processor?
Yeah. I think we could we could yeah.
Let's do that. So
you need to let let's add another query.
Keep that query here and create a new
one. There's a button, add query. Yeah. And
then
yeah. So you can do a name. So
open
exactly. Yeah. Write the same selector. And then
after, at the end, when you want to
look for a world, it is a pipe
equal. If you want to do a search
pipe equal and then space, and then, yeah,
you put the world that you want to
find.
So this is case sensitive?
Yep.
I think that's fine. Yeah. No. It's gonna
yeah. That should be that should be fine.
So if you run that, it will run
both query.
And it hasn't fine, I think. We may
have fallen out of the five minute window.
I'm not sure. I'm not oh, yeah. You're
right. Yeah. Yeah. That's the case. Yeah. Yeah.
It's been over five minutes since we started
since we scaled that up, so I was
kind of watching for it. Yeah.
So we found four
line that contained that one across all the
pods.
Right? And
that's that's that's kind of like a.
So there's so there's multiple option. Here, we
do
a match of the world. But we can
do a regex, which is instead
of using pipe equal, it's pipe tilde.
And then you can write regex. So obviously,
that's a valid regex, what you have here,
too.
But you could write
yeah. You can show me your Array two
skill.
We'll keep it simple, right?
Yeah. Exactly. Good
call.
But yeah, you can write this is how
you and you can chain them. So
you could do
it contains
the default, but you can chain another one
at the end.
So if you go at the end and
you go another pipe equal, you can have
another one. Yeah. You can chain multiple of
Default.
So the both clause needs to be fulfilled.
Sorry. Can you say that last bit again?
Yeah.
Both both both of those clause need to
be fulfilled. Yeah. That's gonna be fine. Yeah.
There we go. Yeah.
I mean, I don't have any Rawkode logs,
but it did filter on default lifecycle, which
is what I wanted.
Just throwing in random bits of regex just
to, you know, just to check that it
works.
I guess Yeah. So you can chain as
much as you want. And then after, there's
the negative one. So if you need to,
you can instead of pipe,
you can do exclamation mark. And that's gonna
do the negative one. So everything that doesn't
contain.
Alright. Yep.
I mean, I should probably just return nothing.
Would've thought.
That Oh, no. There's other defaults that are
in life cycle. Okay. That actually worked then.
Cool.
Nice.
Yep.
And the estimation
training thing. You know, it feels like a
data transformation. You know, I've got all of
my logs. I wanna do a filter. I
wanna do a filter. I wanna do a
filter. And I wanna get something at the
end. And it it's, again, intuitive and, you
know, similar to some programming languages that I've
worked with as well. So
I think that. Yeah. The idea is it
should feel like a CLI a bit. So
you're piping
and processing
from left to right data.
That's
the idea. So that's the search. Search are
so that's the most powerful way to search
data.
If you look at your first query at
the top, you can insert the search in
between the square brackets and the label matcher
to count
the rates of logs, but for only a
specific word.
So is that just this bit here?
You
can copy everything and replace the label match
at the top here.
Only the yeah,
To this. Yeah. Replace this. Yeah.
And then run that.
Nice. Right. So, yeah.
It's
I don't know if it's there's not enough
data, I think, to show.
Maybe try to
Yeah. There might not be enough data for
the the rate to show. But The rate
to show. Yeah. But the the apparently,
there's one point somewhere. I'm not sure where
it is because it shows like a zero
to two.
Yeah. No idea.
But try to to to, like,
do a search that hits a bit more
without the the second player. Let's take off
the
oh, oh, you can switch also to another
container. Maybe look here. Yeah. Here we go.
So it's not the most most
nice graph
that I've seen.
Know? Okay. So we could use not just
a label select or an metric queries, but
a a fill log query to do the
filtering and then perform aggregations or metrics on
top of those log data, which is very
nice and neat. Yeah.
Yeah. That's correct. So you can do search.
And once you have your search so, for
instance, you can look at, you know,
do I have an error in the last
six hour? And if you find an error,
you can try to look at, was this
error there yesterday too? And you can start
to do a rate and look at, you
know, since when this error is happening, how
often it's happening. So you can do those
kind of operation.
And so to remember everything that is inside
parentheses,
it's the selector of the stream of the
the the actual log. And everything that is
a function
will be used to extract metric, so like
in Prometheus.
Piping goes with log, and then function goes
with metric.
Okay, cool.
You happy to take a couple more questions
from the audience just now before we move
on?
Yep.
Okay. So we got a question here from
Andres.
How does Loki compare to Graylog or Logstash?
Yeah.
So
Logstash,
it doesn't really compare to because Logstash is
an agent.
But if we look at Pontail and
Logstash,
I think Pontail is in Go. And as
I was saying at the beginning,
the service discovery to
find the labels is very much the same
as Prometheus.
So that's the big difference.
Logstash is a is a bit more
a bit more focused on
working on your logs and
modifying them or aggregating and transforming the logs.
Promptile does that a bit, but that's not
the
The the that's why that's not why we
created.
It's more like to ship logs.
And gray logs, I mean, I've I never
really used gray log, but I know exactly
what it is. And it's the same idea.
Loki and and gray logs are of the
same purpose. You can send logs to
to to Graylog and aggregate.
So I think the biggest difference is that
Loki is inspired by Prometheus. So if you're
already running Prometheus,
it makes your experience a bit more easier.
And it's all integrated in Grafana.
And I don't think Graylog is put in
Grafana.
So what do you you know, let's just
assume I'm an operator for a production Kubernetes
cluster. We have all this log data and
I'm setting down
and I have to make the decision. Do
I install Loki to my cluster or Elasticsearch
or both? Like,
how do people evaluate and make that decision?
Yeah. I think if it's if it's so
if it was me,
and I'm also, you know, doing operation in
my
in my in my job, and if it's
for logs, I will go for Loki.
I will always go for Loki with logs
because that's what it has been created for.
After,
if I'm building a shop
and I know that some of my customer
will need to search for a given world
to find a specific product, I will use
Elasticsearch for that to store the information of
my
store.
But you can quickly realize the difference between
the two is one of them is going
to probably receive
a lot of traffic. The other one should
only receive, I don't know, a couple of
thousand of product that you have.
And that should make it a bit more
easy to easier to scale your Elastic cluster
compared to Loki.
So it really depends on the use case.
That's what I want to say.
Elastic is very good for indexing data and
your
items using
LUCEN queries.
Loki is really good at logs. That's what
it does
at best. Yeah. So let's kinda talk about
the the difference there as well. Like, Elasticsearch
indexes everything,
I believe. It does full text search and
has indices for it. Everything
every document that you throw into it is
is is really index. Loki, you have to
be a lot more explicit about what we
want to index. It's not am am I
right in saying that Loki can index stuff,
I just have to tell it which fields
I I care about. Is that correct?
Yeah. That's correct. So by default,
like you like you've seen when we install
it with Elm, we choose a couple of
a couple of labels that we think are
good out of your own label from Kubernetes.
But you can configure that. You can add
more. You can extract directly from the log
line, the label, like the label. If you
want to have the label, you can extract
a bit more. You can do that. But
by default, usually, for most of the people,
it should be fine, you know, what we
have configured here.
Okay.
We have another question, which I think leads
in nicely to what we want to show
next, which is kind of maybe dashboarding
and such. So Frank has asked,
is it possible when a customer found a
dashboard with a logs panel for a filtered
set of Loki logs to activate this expand
functionality
like an explorer view?
Yeah.
I think it is. So I think
if
the question is, can we have this query
here
inside
a dashboard, the answer the the answer is
yes. We can have that.
Okay. Let's let's take a look at the
dashboard and stuff then. So
we build a dashboard with a a mix
of metrics and log data? Just a really
simple Yeah.
Yeah.
Let's do a let's do that. Alright.
So you want me just to click create
dashboard?
Yep. There we go.
And then we wanna add
panel icon. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's start with a metric. So look
at promoters maybe if you wanna add metrics.
K. So you need to select, yeah, promoters.
Metric, I think you should You can find
one.
I'm thinking what we're have here. Oh, we
have cAdvisor
running. It's good. Can look at CPU from
cAdvisor.
Oh, shit.
That's
maybe it's container. Maybe it's container.
Yeah.
Load average over ten seconds?
Zero. But it is a metric. So
And then just apply?
Yeah. The other
yeah. We need to
I'm not sure this was one
Alright. A great Excellent. But the load average
the the load yeah. That's the what I
was thinking.
As
yeah. CPU CPU is not a bad one,
but, yeah, let's take another one. Node
or we can do a Pontail, like a
a Pontail total line received, something like that.
There's a Pontail somewhere. I've seen it.
Yeah. Because we we yep. And then what
do we have?
Log byte total is not bad. Log entry
log read byte total. Yeah. Let's do that.
So you want to
write and sum
all of this. So sum
parentheses
rates.
Yeah. So
if you want to buy, I think a
pod will be will be there. We can
do pod, most likely. You can do some
buy, though. Yeah. And then the rate at
the end before
yeah. Right here, and it's the entire yeah.
Five minutes is good.
Or one minute.
I think aggregate was some
Yeah. No. Put one minute. I think it's
better.
Yeah. Okay.
Alright.
Yeah. Maybe the
it was working.
Yeah. I broke it.
Maybe it's the the the part that doesn't
exist, possibly.
But it it was returning data. Right?
That's not a good query.
If yeah. Go back and just do a
sum, right, like, resolve the bipod. Remove the
the bipod just to make sure that we're
not missing.
Yeah.
Are we still on the parameters at the
top?
Just call it up. I'm not showing it
anymore.
Yeah. I broke it.
There we go. Oh,
here we go. It's just leaving. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean,
rates rates should should give you, like, the
The change over time. Yeah. Yeah. The change
over time.
And then there's not a lot of there's
not a lot success or the rate rate.
Yeah. Well
Yeah. There we go. Okay. Yeah, maybe one
minute was not a good idea. Maybe you
need something bigger. Because if the Skype interval
is too small, then that could cause a
problem.
But yeah, five minutes is good. And
that's in bytes. So I think in the
fields
next panel, you can put bytes there if
you want to make it more more fun.
So there's a field tab. So you're on
the panel tab. Next to the panel, there's
like a field.
Yeah. And then in unit, you can choose
I think it's data or byte. Yeah.
I see. Yeah.
SI.
Yeah.
So that's the rate of logs that we
receive over time, which is a good burst
at the beginning. And then after, it's
a bit less. But yeah, you can look
at the last hour, maybe,
instead of six hours. So it's going to
look a bit better.
Yeah, that makes more sense. There we go.
Alright. So that's that's a metric from point
is metric metric panel.
Now what we can do is add another
one,
and let's let's put the logs of Promptail
next to it.
So panel, if you go so if you
click on Loki, and then
on visualization,
on the far right visualization,
this yeah.
You can choose a log panel somewhere.
Logs.
Yep.
Alright. And now let's do
name Pontail, if you have it. You should
have it. No. So I think it's because
we don't have the name. So it's app.
App. Yeah.
You should use consistent
labeling name.
Yeah. There's app. There's Nothing like us. There's
case app. It's just so variable. Yeah. Alright.
And then I'll just need to So
let's try to see if we can find
something a bit better, like
find the errors or
try to to pipe into,
like, tail.
Yeah. So pipe equal tail.
Then look for the word tail. So just
to show that we can do a search
here. So it's, I think, tail is, yeah,
not a capital t.
Yeah. You can do that, but it's yeah.
Tilde. Yeah.
Nice. And you can save that.
Yeah. And you can usually, I like to
make my my lock panel
a bit bigger. So use a use a
single hole and make it use
the the the whole
row. It's much better.
Nice. So yeah, that's
the beginning. But you can build very interesting
dashboard.
Oh, nice. I filtered the when I sorry,
I did the zoom and the metrics. Then
I actually zoomed in and filtered the logs
as well.
Yeah. So you can see the logs that
if there were any logs that contain tail
at this moment in time, which is kind
of nice for errors, right?
I don't think we have any errors. But
maybe we can find some. But it's kind
of nice to see when you have an
error, can you correlate that with a metric
and find the metric where the error was
happening? So
being able to mix the two is kind
of nice. It's being able to mix two
different signals.
Nice. I like that.
Yeah. And you can jump directly to explore.
So when
you have a dashboard like this, when you
click on the on the panel at the
top, the panel title, then you can go
directly on explore from that query. You can
do explore here.
And it goes to explore, and you can
start exploring. Yeah. Save it.
That's
our work.
I need to ship this to prod layer.
So
There you go. Yeah. And I get my
And and you keep yeah. And you keep
the query, and you can maybe
improve the query and, you know, try to
find a bit more
information for what you're looking for.
I'm
amazed to see that those logs are the
prompt tail one are still in
the wrong format.
I think this was we changed the configuration
at 45.
Okay. One forty five. It's time Can we
We could restart prompt if you want. No.
That'll be it. Okay. Can we look at
the can we look at Loki Loki logs
for instance, maybe?
Of course, we can. Yeah. Upload.
Yeah.
And then remove the remove this. Yeah. Now
you're getting good at Okay.
Alright. So, yeah, I wanted to show you
a bit more
interesting queries that we can do. And because
I know a lot of Loki logs,
obviously, I expect developers to know a bit
more about what they are logging.
So that makes it more interesting when you
want to play with your logs. So I
know that Loki
is kind of like logging every time you
make a query.
It's logging the query itself.
And I want to show you, let's try
to show only that.
Imagine you have a database. Every time someone
does a query, you want to create a
dashboard that shows all the queries that have
been made by the user.
So
let's use the equal here. Let's use the
equal instead of the yeah, equal. And then
use
metric.
Go, and then there's a comma. You can
see in the first line.
Yeah, metric. Go.
There's asset metric.
Metrics.
That makes sense.
Yeah. And then run that.
And we're gonna be able to find
oh, yeah.
And now we can see only the logline
that are showing metrics.
What's nice here is what we can do
is we can start using and pass that
logline. So we haven't done that yet, but
let's do that. So this logline is in
log format. That's what we call log format.
So it's a key value pair. It's a
key equal value,
and then space, another key equal value.
And it's very human readable as opposed to
JSON.
And in the query, let's
look at currently the
let's add a pipe
and then log format.
So L O G yeah, it's going to
suggest it. Yeah, this one.
Right, so hit Enter.
Now, if you look at the labels of
any of those logline, you're going to see
that something has changed.
And there's way more labels. There, there are.
And that's
basically
all the key value pair of the logline
itself.
They have been extracted,
and you can now use them as labels.
So that means you can aggregate. You can
use them to search, filter.
And and we can even transform some of
them into metrics.
So you can see there's a status here.
Yep.
200. So you could technically do a rate
per status now. If you wrap everything with
a rate a a sum by rate.
So we do sum by stages.
And then you need the you need the,
yeah, you need the
bracket at the end right after the
yeah. Square bracket right after the end of
the log queries.
It's inside. Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah.
Here we go. So we can see by
status now. Alright. So status is not labeled.
This will
fail.
And
theory, me paste this back. We we should
be able to see some failed ones there?
No? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I don't know if we show
them as a status to
I think the 400, we don't we just
this is a code that doesn't get triggered
by 400,
so that's why you don't see it. You
don't see it there. It will actually need
to crash
to see it. But
you can add another query and and look
at the query dot go.
Yeah. Click on other query, and then copy
this selector
with, yeah, everything except and you can look
at if you can see now the font.
I don't think you will see it. Remove
the standby and the rate
to see the logs. Oh, it's got the
logs. Right. Okay. Good. Yeah. Let's let's let's
look at the logs, see if all the
bad queries that you've made will
show up.
Yeah. I like to have always two query
when I'm crafting queries. One to show the
logs so I can see what I'm working
on, and one which is the metric one
that I'm crafting.
Can you see? No. You see it doesn't
actually show. However, there is one label that
is interesting. As you can see the type,
query type.
There's metric and there's probably filter. So if
you change the sum
by status, you change it by query type,
you're going to see different type of queries
instead.
Does it show you the number of results
for a query? No?
No.
No. Not no. But it shows you all
those all those things. So at the top,
yeah, I've changed the status,
send by query type query underscore type. Yeah.
And now you can see that there is
different
Metric different type of queries. Limited query.
Yeah, limited is a search. And that's Filter
is also a search.
So that's yeah. So you can see the
different type of query that have been made.
And you can imagine if you are SRE.
There's a lot of information that you have
in your logs, you can aggregate now
by extracting those labels.
Yeah. There's a there there's there's more that
we can we can do. We can look
at how to use those those
numbers. You see the duration here?
Inside the logline, you can see that the
that metric took four milliseconds.
We can use those to maybe graph a
quantile. If you if you want, we can
do that. Okay. Can we
contrive something?
So we have where we use the log
format
here,
we're bringing in a whole bunch of extra
labels into our
each record in the stream
Mhmm. Which means that we have access to
the query itself.
Could we contrive a situation where if we
query for Rawkode
and then count the currencies of that search
over time and then that means we can
do loads of them, stop it, loads of
them, just to try and see how this
works together. Because I'm curious, like, we've not
told it to index the query. Right? That's
something that comes in from the log prompt.
Yeah. Okay. And it wouldn't be a bad
idea to index it because, you know, the
of it could be very high.
So don't do that. However,
the log format, the pipeline format that you
did is doing that at query time, is
actually extracting the labels
from the log line. It's not coming from
the index. But you can still use it
to run aggregation.
Yeah. So if I add another query here
and say this
and then say where Rawkode I mean, the
first time I run this, we're gonna get
nothing or maybe itself. I'm not sure.
Nothing, I think.
Yeah. It's mixing the two. Yeah. It's mixing
the two.
You can hide it. There's a there's a
button on the yeah. You click on that
and it's gonna hide it. Okay. So now
I've got that one request for Rawkode. If
I do it again, we should see two.
Alright. Okay. So we can, like, fake the
rate essentially by just Yeah. You can. Yeah.
Alright.
So should we try and rate the searches
for Rawkode every five seconds?
Yeah. And then that will give us a
draft. So I'm assuming if I just come
in here,
query
Mhmm. Rawkode
five seconds.
Is that right? Yeah. That's correct.
Five second is a is a bit low.
You need to make a make a big
gap because this is a range that it's
gonna search for.
Oh, this is the oh, okay. I thought
it was how many I thought I was
doing a rate over
five seconds. Okay. So let's do five minutes.
We should return them all.
Yep. So
what's that rate over? How does it determine
the window?
So
the window is
at the top, the
time selector that you have.
So currently, you are on, what, an hour,
I think? So it's going to split the
hour into multiple point. And for each point,
it's going to look back at five minutes.
Yeah. So it's an hour.
Okay. So why did five seconds not show
me how many
searches for Rawkode I had? Oh, it did.
We were just It does. It Yeah. But
you're going to miss my point is you're
going miss a couple of them if you
if you do just do five. You're going
to see some, but you're to miss a
couple of them.
Okay. So
Because five seconds, if you don't know what
the interval is between each point. So it's
exactly like Prometheus, the query. So this is
a query range.
A query range is basically
an instant query that is executed
for given steps or every depending on the
the interval, the total interval. So if it's
a one hour, it's probably gonna do 60
step,
one for each second.
Looking at five seconds, yeah, you're gonna probably
hit all the the points. But if you
are looking sub second, you will miss a
couple of data because for each point, you
will not look at all the point in
the in the window.
Okay. That makes sense. I've got one follow-up
question then. So
this, I completely
understand.
That's we've got disabled right now, so I'm
gonna ignore it. But here,
we're just searching the entire log line for
Rawkode.
Can I only search the query and I
guess that would come after I do the
log format? Can I then,
how would I only search on the query
field for Rawkode?
Yeah. No. That's a that's a good good
question. So all the labels that you have
extracted now can be used here.
So you can use query equal, for instance.
And that's like this is
it's less fast. It's
a bit slower than doing a pipe search
because pipe search are really the first thing
that happen. But if you do a search
here, it's going to happen after the log
format. So he still needs to process all
the log line one by one. But it's
not a pipe equal. It's pipe this time.
Just pipe. And then here, you can add
any labels that you want. And there's a
lot of things that you can do. So
let's start with equal
the name, yeah?
Like that?
Yeah.
Yeah. I think you're gonna need to hide
now you hide it. Yeah. Let's let's see.
Let's remove the the log query. Plus, it
looks like it's
not having a good time.
Remove this query?
No. The the first query, the at the
top, like, this one. Yeah. I think that's
the one that's struggling. Yeah.
Yep.
Oh, it didn't find any.
Maybe you need to look back in
Let's
just try
Let's just make sure.
Let's make sure that it's query equal.
Ah, you see there's like a, yeah,
Query I think it is.
So is there is there a special syntax
here? I mean, is is this just a
regular filter? No. No. Okay. No. No. It's
a it's a label of we call it
label filter. So you need label equal on
yeah. But it's and it's the yeah. And
it's the part.
Yeah. That's not gonna work. You need the
yeah. He needs to know if it's a
string. So
yeah. I know. Don't don't yeah. That's not
gonna work too.
I'm just gonna keep taking No. I think
it should it should work there what you
did at first. Like, let's try again.
Yeah. You need to include to quote it.
Yeah.
Quote it.
Can you increase maybe the window?
I don't know. What's the is it one
hour? Fifteen minutes.
Thirty minutes. Yeah, it's not coming up. So
let's
try duration
instead. So let's try duration.
And then you do
below
five seconds,
s with s.
Do we yeah.
Alright. So can we see those logline that
you're trying to find?
Yeah. So that Because it's query
Yeah. So there's one there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
It's because
the label one, like, a is
a real. It's not like a grep.
Right? So the query the real query is
app equal Loki log format query. You see
what I mean?
So you need to do, like, a regex.
So you can you can filter with those
now. So you can do a if you
want. I do this. Yep.
That's going to work.
It
should
have worked.
Why is it not working?
Yeah.
I just Try Loki instead.
Try try Loki maybe instead of yeah. Just
to see if
Yeah. So is the label query exist?
Now I'm now I'm curious.
Can you, yeah, remove everything? Look at just
this. Yeah. Look at the labels.
That's what?
That's the Oh, yeah. Yeah. We need the
metrics. Yeah.
Let me do equal
yeah.
What?
Wait. Maybe the quotes. I didn't need the
quotes. Right? No. Yeah. No. You need it.
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
No. You needed to to say it's a
string.
But that was working. Right?
That was saying that's just a basic query
of find Rawkode in my log, I thought.
What have I done? Yeah. I'm I'm
I'm also impressed that it doesn't work, but
it should be working.
When in time Yeah. Let's just go back
to explore. Like,
Loki.
And what we were gonna do was
app
equals
Loki.
And then let's get all the logs for
the last fifteen minutes.
And then
We can see it here. Yeah. We can
see
Do a log format to see the labels
if we
For my own sanity, just wanna walk through
those things that didn't work. I don't know
why they didn't work. Yeah. That's I think
a friend was a little confused. Okay. That's
better.
Alright. Let's blame Grafana. Yeah. That's good.
So so we have query here. So what
we were saying was So this is a
global search, but we wanna do it as
the individual filter search. And you're saying I
could just rejects?
Yes. Like so.
Mhmm.
But it doesn't want to. Yeah. Let's let's
maybe try This is a good one.
It doesn't want to. But you can do
a yeah. The query the query was the
just I'm I'm a
if you click on the
logline
yeah. Click on it to see the labels.
Yeah. It's the
Well, the duration one worked. Let's try
level info.
Yeah. Let's try level info because this is
gonna be a call.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. That works fine. That works. Yeah.
I think there's a mistake somewhere in the
query that we're we're doing. I'm gonna try
this. Yeah. This is
yeah. Try yeah. Yeah. Okay. Something wrong with
that potentially.
Okay. Let's just ignore that.
But and for dead work. Okay. So once
we've got log format, we can then query
individual
labels Yeah. Then the data. Of course, you
were very clear that there's a performance penalty
for this because this all happens on the
stream and real time
can be a little CPU intensive. But that
was Yeah. Really, really cool. But that yeah.
But that's what Loki has been built for.
Right? It has been built for you to
use
resources
when you need it to, not when you're
ingesting.
So when you query, we expect you to
burn some CPU because you're going to scan
data. You're going to scan a lot data.
There's a little index.
So since the index is very small, we
expect you to have to need to do
those scan to find what you want
to find.
We can rewrite the logline. So maybe we
can look at this if you Yeah, sure.
Let's do it.
So right
after, you can pipe in. There's
an operation name, line format.
And it's using your favorite
Go
template. Go template. Yeah. So yeah, exactly. Yeah,
exactly. So let's try dot query.
Yeah, Ladle, yeah, for instance. I think you
need the
yeah, I'm not sure. I'm Oh, yeah. Think
it
needs to be yeah, I think you need
to yeah, exactly.
All right. So you can even add a
smiley if you know how to
do an image con.
I actually know. Oh, you know how to.
Nice.
It didn't work. I don't know what's my
emoji.
I don't know. It should be working. I
use it a lot of time.
Let's try But you can see the logline
is is
yeah. Don't know if the yeah.
No. Oh, well. It doesn't it doesn't want
to. But we we do get there. Yeah.
Sorry. On your go. Yeah.
And,
yeah, that that's that's pretty cool because you
can use this format.
If if the log line were not very
sane, you can pass it, rewrite it, make
it more readable. And you can use that
in a dashboard again, you know, if you
want to have, like, a table showing only
duration or only
information that you want. Yeah. That's what I
was as soon as you showed me the
the the line format here, and I can
assume what we were working here. I said,
oh, we're we're now able to build, like,
tabular data. So does that mean can I
change the visualization on this to to be
a table? Like, if I change the
I don't know. I don't know if we
support that now. No. At at least not
in explore.
But I think in the dashboard, it it
works. But I'm not 100% sure. We can
give it to try if you want. But
it needs to be a dashboard.
My emojis have
broken Grafana. Broken broken Grafana. Yeah. I can
see that. I'm just gonna copy this query.
Let's go back to our dashboard that we
built.
I'm sure I could have just added that
to the dashboard, but my Grafana is not
great.
Let's do ads.
Let's do row.
Nope. That didn't do that. Okay. Panel.
Better.
We wanted to do a Loki query.
We want to drop in this.
We've got a line format, which needs
And we did,
that's the level
query.
Was it query status?
No. It's just status. Status.
Yeah.
And
then we'll do the query.
You can even add labels that are from
the index if you want to add the
the app
or the the the container from which container
it comes from. There's a you know, all
the all the labels are are available.
Okay.
So we can we
can probably just take off
the Rawkode. Yeah.
The Envoy is not really doing much, but
let's just take it off anyway.
Yeah. Not all the logline is gonna have
this
this query label,
but that's okay.
Oh, and it's actually offering to switch to
a table. Oh, interesting. Oh, never seen it.
Fancy.
But it actually detected that we had
oh, no, but it's not got the fields
that I told it to have. No.
But maybe you can change maybe you can
change the
yeah. I'm not an expert on that,
but I think it's possible to select, like,
the in the transformation, like, the labels as
a field maybe.
Well, we do have the logs and exactly
the format that we expect.
Let's try that again.
Oh, this is the line. Okay. So we
probably have to It's just the line.
Got it. Yeah. So pretty cool. But I
think I
it's a
nice feature feature request.
I'll take this back
to the GraphQL team.
Nice.
I like it.
There's one last thing that we haven't that
we haven't really show
about the language is extracting
value,
like a numerical value from the logline and
use them as a metric query. That's
the last most difficult type of query that
we can do.
But they're really cool because there's a lot
of people out there that have a counter
or
speed or
duration in their logline. And they want to
maybe graph the average or things like that,
or the quintile, the max, or the mean.
And we can do that with Loki.
All right. Do you want to walk me
through it?
Yeah. So you don't need this
line format anymore. Everything can
be removed. You
still need the log
the line format, you don't need it, but
you still need the log format because we
want to use one of the fields.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to use the unwrap. So it's u
n w
so u n yeah, wrap. And then the
name of the label that we want to
unwrap. So unwrap means use that label as
sample value.
Let's use maybe
duration.
So it doesn't need parentheses.
So yeah, to remember that is very easy.
Everything about the logline,
it doesn't need parentheses. It's all
pipe.
So
we
need to make sure that it's only
yeah. So let's do an average over time
of all of this.
Average underscore
over time. So we need the over time,
yeah, over time.
And then you need yeah. But the
bracket needs to be inside.
And you need at the end to add
a by. Let's do a by
pod. Yeah, it's a by pod.
No, just by. And then parentheses open and
close. Grafana is disturbing
us here.
Just by
enclosing to parentheses pod.
Sorry, I missed that last bit.
Yeah,
just add.
So remove bytes All right. Okay. And add
parentheses,
open parentheses,
and then part. Yeah, that's so there will
be probably errors because duration
doesn't really
exist on all the logline.
So there's two options. Either we can skip
those,
or we can
filter them manually. I think skip is better.
So at the end of right after duration,
you can add another pipe.
And there is a special key one for
the errors. It's underscore underscore,
error underscore underscore.
And we can do equal
empty
string.
So that means we're going to consider only
a logline that doesn't have an error. Because
the error label is basically added every time
there's an issue passing the logline.
So that should be working.
You need to switch that to a graph,
I believe,
on the visualization.
Right. So it doesn't find anything.
And it's because duration so this is going
to be confusing. But duration
is in a format.
It's in GoDuration format.
And so we need to tell the unwrap
how to pass that. And you just need
to enclose duration with duration again.
So open parentheses here and add duration inside
the parentheses. Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. So yeah, normally you will name
duration.
You will name your own
But that's the reason why. We need to
tell it. If it's bytes, so there's another
one, which is throughput.
And you can switch if you want. You
can do the first duration. You could switch
it to bytes
with S at the end.
And then duration by throughput. Yeah.
And this is going to be the average
throughput per query
in bytes.
Okay. So we have a label selector
with a log format.
The unwrap is extracting one of the values
from the log lanes where we're telling it
which type of value it is. So we
try doing a duration duration
and we also tell in it that throughput
is abates.
We're then piping through to where error equals
zero just to filter out any lines that
didn't have a duration and we've got the
average over time by a five minute
window
and then we group that bipod
using.
Exactly. But
that's a very powerful query because
the throughput here is actually a value that
is inside the logline.
And I can aggregate all the value of
the throughput that exists in my logline to
see, you know, over time how it looks
like, like the average.
So this is in bytes.
But that that can be very useful when
you're looking at duration if you want to
do you can even do a quantile on
top of this. So things about NGINX
logline that outputs
the duration in seconds,
and you can get the average
latency in seconds without having to instrument promoters,
right, just with the logs.
By using the quantile, I can see what
are 99%
of my requests returning under to see when
I've got major performance problems or
Yeah. Problems in general, I guess, to be
fair. Okay. Yeah.
Very very cool. There's
a lot to cover. Well, look. There's
Yeah. There's a lot. Yeah.
But I could I could already see where
it fits in to my to my stack.
What I wanna be doing with it. Getting
all those logs from my containers into it.
The ability to work with both logs
and aggregations of them into metrics, I think
is is almost a superpower. I love being
able to have that side by side and
a graph on a dashboard and really help
just increase
that, you know, understanding I have of all
my systems. So yeah. Yeah. Awesome. Very cool.
Thank you for for coming on and sharing
that with us today.
Yeah. I think that we did we did
good. I was expecting more
more issues along the way, but you did
well with your community skills.
Yeah.
Well, you know, you rave it off all
of those queries definitely kept things running smooth,
so I definitely appreciate that.
Although, we'll need to work out what happened
with that little magic equals regex we had
in our labels. Yeah. I'll open an issue
for you. There you go. There's my contribution
for Nice. Nice.
Love it.
Alright. Well Thanks a lot. We we don't
have any more questions, but, you know, to
the people watching, thank you very much for
for tuning in, and I hope you can
see the power and flexibility of Loki. I
hope you get it deployed to your systems.
Feel free to ask any questions on the
YouTube chat and the Discord or reach out
to us on Twitter, and we'll do our
best to help you out.
Sarah, thank you for joining me again. It
was great just to go through this. You
have a really good talent for just guiding
and explaining things as she goes. Thank you
for doing that. Nice.
Nice day. Thank you for having me. It
was very nice. I enjoyed it. Alright. Have
a great day. I'll speak to you soon.
Bye. Thank you. Bye.